what up space fam goes in here from
anime up we're back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story this
time around we got a lot to cover like
the true identity slash identities of
vegapunk Bonnie's connection to Kuma
revealed why cp0 is returning the
shocking reason why they're returning
actually and the non-yamoto character
was actually joined the straw hats so
make sure to stay tuned for this packed
chapter trailer parking with it and
smash that like button if you enjoyed
these weekly one piece reviews I want to
keep them coming make this the video you
subscribe if you haven't already and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all this chapter is called
Adventure in the Land of Science and we
start where we left off last time with
vegapunk's cool Mecca and some of our
straw hats including Zorro I love seeing
Frankie Fanboy over Vega punk as he says
they're his role model he even comments
how he spent two years in megapunk's
Hometown even after going through Vega
Punk's lab there was still a load of
stuff he didn't get into so I think this
Arc will be a great opportunity for
Frankie growth under the tutelage of
vegapunk and of course people are still
obsessing over the giant Mecca and I get
it while watching Code Geass and the
Gundam series I definitely fantasized
about how cool it would be to have one
of those meccas myself and if you're
like me and you thought about it too
then you definitely want to smash that
like button I love how usop thinks to
himself that he can't wait to show the
mecca to Luffy and Chopper and then we
see Sanji also reacting and all like
everyone else but of course he's
actually focusing on the stunning lady
rather than on the robot Robin is the
one that gets down to business saying
she's never heard of vegapunk being a
woman and also that the girl in front of
them is too young since vegapunk has
been active so long and this could have
been explained in a variety of ways like
the whole having a cyborg body thing but
as many of you noticed last time there
was a punk too on this Punk shirt and
that does come into play here in reality
Punk 2 explains this isn't the main
Stella body but Punk 2 Vega Punk Lilith
more on this whole aspect of vegapunk
later on in the chapter for now punk 2
tells them that since they run through
their research funds in a jiffy she'll
allow them to skedaddle if they just
relinquish their valuables I love
vegapunk's personality here everything
for money so that it could work more on
Research completely obsessed just as a
mad scientist should be Nami is
hilarious when she says what kind of
rescue do you call this only for Punk 2
to again reiterate this is not a rescue
weaponized sea beasts or summon but the
funny thing is they all seem to be based
on non-sea animals like giraffes and
lions but with scales Frankie for his
part is still excited to see the Seabees
while usop is already starting to get
worried here Zorro though is cool stoic
and calm as always then Punk 2 gets a
message not to underestimate them it's
pointed out that that's pirate Hunter
Zorro who has a 1.11 billion Bounty it's
also pointed out how comsoro is and how
Zorro knows punctu is in his range and
he can end them in an instant the same
goes for Robin CBS or not they know how
to prioritize the most essential targets
first because of the so-called imbeciles
that odd over Punk 2 and the inventions
she was lulled into a false sense of
secure dirty I like how everyone played
a role here in getting the upper hand
against Punk 2 even if they didn't know
what they were doing then Zoro finally
speaks to vegapunk and when Zoro speaks
we all listen he says there's something
I want from you so you'd better play
nice got it end quote so cool man so
cool and then Punk one is shown from the
back they're called Shaka or logic and
this one says bring them I have an
interest in that crew ironically it's
also pointed out that only Punk 2 the
one looking like a young girl has the
old man voice this one doesn't appear to
but what is really cool about Punk one
is that they wear a helmet that looks to
be inspired from Daft Punk and that
would obviously make sense with the punk
parallel as well as a huge fan of Daft
Punk I absolutely love that detail we
then jump to Luffy and Bonnie as I
guessed Bonnie reveals that Kuma is her
father and that vegapunk turned him into
a cyborg which is not as cool as Luffy
thinks because he completely lost his
sense of self she says with tears in her
eyes that he's nothing but a living
weapon now Jim base says it's
unforgivable while Luffy keeps calling
Bonnie Boogie Bonnie also mentioned that
she has some news about Sabo since she
met him at marijuana but comments that
she can Spill the Beans later which is a
huge tease and something we have to look
forward to in the upcoming chapters they
enter a room and see cool stuff like a
giant robot and a space monster and just
futuristic stuff all around it turns out
though that most of this stuff is just a
hologram and when they find out that the
food is a hologram as well Luffy Bonnie
and Chopper really get upset jinbei is
the voice of reason here although he's
never seen one he concludes it must be a
hologram and Bonnie is the one that
points out that it is a 3D image made of
light and even adds that you see them in
comics and science fiction stuff which
is pretty meta and great Luffy thinks
that the robot must be a hologram too
since no one could make something like
that although of course we know that
vegapan can and did as the other straw
had saw then they run into Punk six also
a girl design and the hair actually
reminds me of shanks's daughter's hair
from the new movie it's playing that
this is a winter Island but with the
magic of science they can set it to
Tropical mode imagine if instead of
snowbirding to a warm country over the
winter you could just set your country
to Tropical pretty cool technology I
must say Chopper notes that punk six is
as big as kaido and when Luffy punches
it to see if it's a hologram it
backfires Punk six punches him back and
sends him flying he hits into the
machine with the pictures of food on it
and it produces Burgers and Fries here
we pretty much see stuff available in
Tokyo today but even more extreme
versions of it Luffy Bonnie and Chopper
pig out and I really like Luffy and
Bonnie's shared love of food I must say
this dynamic between the two of them is
really growing on me we're told the
unmanned cooking device can turn raw
ingredients into one of 500 unique
dishes in under a minute it's added that
the make do with what you've got mode is
the best and I love that Oda added that
last mode because I was wondering what
happens if some ingredients run out
before others and you can't really get
what you wanted of course if you're rich
enough you you can probably have it
refilled every day Punk 6 points out
that they can't be too happy since the
lack of competent Engineers means that
it can't be mass produced and wonders if
following the blueprints are really that
hard the lack of funds and resources
clearly upsets Punk six who hits the
dragon-looking creature and if you're
wondering how she was able to punch the
Hologram it's because her photonic
gloves make it possible to physically
interact with light this is a very
interesting idea too and something that
we'll definitely see down the line in
our world we already see it a bit in how
we can interact with augmented reality
through our phones Luffy asks if the
Hologram girl he's looking at isn't real
while Punk six throws in some philosophy
saying debates on what makes something
real are as old as time it's something
you'll have to decide for yourself but I
consider the matter subtle again this is
kind of meta as Oda is also asking us to
consider whether the world of one piece
is real to us and in a very true but
philosophical way I think it is but
perhaps that's enough Philosophy for
this video Punk reveals herself to be
vegapunk and Bonnie says it's lie luff
even mentions he heard that name from
Kobe so Oda is there teasing the fact
that Luffy will probably soon find out
that Kobe's been kidnapped by Blackbeard
then we jump to cp0 they say vegapunk is
still technically a single individual
but that his genius is second only to
his busyness it's revealed that he split
himself into six satellites Rob Lucci
thinks about how much of a pain that is
we then get the crazy twist they're
going to take the new modified Kuma to
Egghead and while not damaging any
Priceless assets they will eliminate
every last Vega Punk Rob Lucci
understandably is not crazy about
eliminating the most useful man in the
world and wonders if it's got something
to do with the ludusia incident where
Sabo was seemingly blown up but he's
told to not ask questions and to not get
them into hot water interesting seeing
Luchi question his superiors though and
I hope he does eventually flip sides
because he is a pretty cool character
but how crazy is that that there are six
Vega punks now and I can't wait to see
how they actually work it said you can
only effectively really focus on one
thing at a time but it seems like the
satellites can act independently from
each other so I wonder if they know what
all the others know or if they have to
share their findings with each other
every day and keep each other updated we
already know that it seems like they can
communicate with each other whenever
they want very interesting stuff and the
fact that vegapunk is now wanted by the
world government means that the straw
hats and vegapunk are definitely teaming
up and it's possible that vegapunk could
even be the new Straw Hat we've been
waiting for or at least one of his
satellites could be yes there is some
overlap between Frankie and vegapunk but
while Frank is primarily the shipwright
vegapunk could primarily be the
scientist either way for a time there is
no doubt in my mind that vegapunk will
be acting with the crew things are
really setting up to be good here with
the straw hat cp0 Vega Punk Kobe and
Blackbeard all potentially being
involved in this oryx Climax and that's
just some of the characters that have
been set up to be in it so far now
channel the piricking within and smash
that like button if you enjoy these
weekly one piece reviews I want to keep
them coming make this the video
subscribe if you haven't already and hit
that notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates while you
wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one piece playlist that includes new
updated videos about all seven yonko all
the Admirals an hour-long video about
Shanks and much more link to that is in
the description thanks again for
watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys